qu'il a dit c'est parti il m'a rattrapé
par les cheveux à d'une peinture bravo
dans le dock johnny par jodie sur notre
félix
incroyable divine et beaucoup d'amour
beaucoup de violence quand ça allait mal
il fallait qu'on ne meurt mais qu on
meurt ensemble oui johnny était égoïste
il fallait qu'on meurt ensemble je me
suis jetée par la fenêtre une fois il
m'a rattrapé par les cheveux t'as pas
intérêt à voir les périgueux les jeans
et les extensions
[Rires]
n'a plus gardé de
lui s'est jetée en arrière d'un escalier
je tenais par les bots nommé t'imagines
à l'époque le par si les gens savaient
rien ça va vous
merci voilà c'était du drama souvent ce
que j'ai vécu à cusset johnny intime
c'est celui qui se réveille la nuit pour
aller manger sa soupe cadets cauchemar
qu'a du mal à dormir qu'il faut 10 lames
il faut lui tenir la main il faut le
rassurer je me suis retrouvé à boire moi
aussi pour comprendre l'autre sadok et
sur netflix en cinq parties et on voit
vraiment à la phase très sombre et j'ai
moi j'ai connu à nîmes lors du neuf de
mon bureau maintenant elle fait tout ce
qui est un peu sophrologie tout ça enfin
c'est une fille formidable qu'elle est
et qui a vécu plein de choses que
j'embrasse très fort et voilà ce dock
oui et elle a très peu parlé de sa
relation johnny et surtout de ces
moments si difficiles qu'elle a qu'elle
a vécu elle explique qu'il lui disait à
l'époque il était quelle était la seule
à pouvoir le sortir de ses démons et de
cet enfer dont elle a tenu elle a tenu
jusqu'au jour où l on pouvait plus parce
que justement elle buvait l'eau si ce
n'était si c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit
c'est réglé dit quand on a fait le job
quand on a fait le job mais c'était en
plein moment où il y avait sylvie vartan
où tout le monde se déchiraient et je
lui ai dit adeline tu parles dans le
dock qu'on faisait ce sur johnny ou pas
elle m'a dit je veux pas en parler puis
finalement on était en confiance et le
médiatisant on dit beaucoup de choses et
ça moi je te dire ce qui est masse de
johnny c'est une montre et je la garde
ça me touche c'est une montre en tout
cas n'a pas des millions à l'ariane tout
ça à la une montre qu'elle garde de
johnny je trouve ça très beau et j'aime
beaucoup cette fille alors quand tu n'es
plus là il est mort le soleil
et ardisson bravo aux tiendra les 5 et
10 avril
[Applaudissements]
audrey crespo à sa famille à sa femme
alors c'est vrai que pardon je bois oui
c'est oui
j'ai une choucroute de la mer qu'elle a
aussi je vais prendre un petit truc non
mais c'est pas sinon c'est une banane
queila gédé
protéine est sportif legata jamais un
match de tennis à une des mes banane ça
ce qu'il a dit audrey crespo mara pour
la conquérir donc effectivement et ses
cours il lui a dit j'ai appelé mon
attachée de presse je lui dis que je
n'arrive pas en fait à faire mon
émission elle m'a dit appelle là je
l'appelle et je lui dit cette phrase
quand tu n'es pas là il est mort le
soleil évidemment chansons de dignité
que j'adore évidemment alors la phrase
est un peu vieille mais ça me donne
l'occasion de vous dire qu'est ce que
vous avez dit de peut-être de plus
ringard ou de plus beau à la personne
que vous aimez ou avec qui vous vivez
toi quand tu es restée une semaine en
couple jean-mi peut-être par exemple
qu'est ce que vous avez dit peut-être de
plus romantique way fogel fukushima
moi surtout que plus beau que j'ai dit
ça va me faire pleurer quoi ah non non
non il était rentré lundi nous l'a dit
nous a dit loi c'est quoi ton prénom
[Rires]
et je n'ai pas retenu
et moi c'est ben moi mon mari l'a fait
le pire compliment qu'on peut faire une
femme et était persuadé que c'était une
phrase très romantique autant je vous
assure qu'ils peuvent y donne à l'époque
contre isabelle remady chérie je te
serai toujours fidèle parce que moi les
jolies femmes j'ai jamais osé les
aborder non
[Applaudissements]
ce thème devant tu sais il est très
amoureux isabelle ma grand mère qui m'a
élevé me disent tous les jours regarde
toi dans la glace et dit toi tous les
jours tu es beau tu es beau tu es le
meilleur ayez une phrase que gm ou que
notre d'un auteur qui disait ne dit pas
de mal de toi laisse les autres le faire
ils le font si bien alors arrête de dire
que tu es moche et tout ça tu es très
bien à lisala donc arrête de dire il
est à toi cette histoire et qui regarde
du toit non oui bah oui il fait pas que
ça mais oui regardez
c'était vous c'est vous monsieur non
mais non
non il est pas là qu'est ce qui t'a dit
travailler quelque chose qu'il m'a déjà
dit dédé tu te commis en bande heures
tu combien vaut le coup si les phrases
un peu cucul au tout début on y tient tu
peux changer une roue de ma bagnole
non c'est moi qui vis de la phrase qu en
fait ils partaient et il apprendra qu on
séparait j'avais dit ouvre ça que quand
tu rentres à la maison et tout et
j'avais mis la clé de chez moi et oui je
lui ai dit voilà la clé de mon coeur et
il ouvrira maintenant dès que tu voudras
pas aussi ringard du cuir à garden of
mais ça fait 12 ans qu'on est ensemble
frérot donc ça a marché alors c'est pas
frérot moi c'est mature on est con
bistrot c'est pas ton pote je suis
animateur là c'est l'animateur la cemac
à 6% ménagères ton très mec que les
chaînes ça frétille était d'avoir
d'accord d'accord est pas très rose ya
pas de couteau il n'y a pas de voile à
tétouan bébé à la béchade du monde
meilleur
mike roux tu passes d'un caisson je
serais vous appelle à vous n'êtes pas
déçu c'était c'était qu'il y des gens
ressentaient mais quitta d'e-sata la
plus belle cette du monde montegnée
gilbert montagné
[Applaudissements]
attendez je vais je vais rire je vais
rester ils peuvent le dire en anglais il
ya deux best aussi noir oui ou c'est non
mais ce choix est lui passé en mer
montagne et la menthe en montagne
lorsque tu parles de ce que tu vois
quand entre les jambes donc tu par
gilbert montagné mais non c'est parce
que
c'est moi qui la bb bb bb bb cc mois ses
animateurs bébé sur une question m'est
donc ça veut dire que tu avais déjà venu
non pas du tout le temps l'échiné il a
imaginé le premier resto une tâche m est
venue elle il m'a dit jean
sommer de huit mois et que toi il
n'était pas un bug c'était mike tyson
connard non
[Applaudissements]
bah oui tu as couché que mike tyson j'ai
pas dit ça arrête h en supplie tu me
dire ça
ne
sortait que mike tyson s'enferre caméra
non mais là ça va pas mais ceci fait
tous les toits qu'il avait accouché ce
n'était pas par l'état je disais ce que
j'ai lu lui m'a dit je vais jetter avec
moi sexuelle romantique que j'ai eu avec
un mec en première date sans avoir
couché avec oui il habite à 36 ans il a
la même
famille ou d imaginer comme il évoque sa
saison l'événement j'ai trouvé ça
incroyable alors il a compris mais c'est
hyper beau comme histoire depuis mardi
non non c'est
une histoire mike tyson ses jeunes amis
ceci dit j'adore gilbert montagné jamais
enseigne aussi vous serez du coup on
fait tous des réversions mais si c'est
la nouvelle phrase que j aimerais bien
savoir les ou parce que si c'est la plus
belle salle belle chatte jamais allé
moi je retiens deux choses tu es sorti
que mike tyson très belle histoire et
bravo et du coup va vous savez cours à
ses intérêts bebel on dit les choses
oui j'ai compris à jouer ou faire cela
parce que j'adore on regarde miss france
pour voir dès qu assez sabri c'est vous
et c'est fabrice éboué alors regardez ce
qu'il a dit on a pas d'extrême d'accord
ce qu'il a dit quand je parle des miss
france dans mon spectacle je suis assez
honnête finalement pascal l'hypocrisie
on nous a parlé qui l'on nous a parlé
qu'il fallait une miss france plus
féministe maintenant ça suffit il faut
le dire au regard de miss france pour
voir des culs et si on veut voir des
femmes intelligentes on regarde
questions pour un champion
ou alors pour les matchs de foot
maintenant on ne tire plus de tirs au
but on va faire des questions
culturelles pour ça ces footballeurs est
intelligent bref on s'en contrefout est
ce que vous êtes d'accord que monsieur
france organise pour tout voir des
jolies filles ou pouvoir des familles
albigeoises qui regardent miss france a
noté 10 ans peut encore y en a moi je
trouve ça pathétique est vrai bah oui
parce que grâce à ce qui vient dire on
fait un bon vin en arrière c'est à dire
qu'une femme a le droit de ne se
pressent de se présenter à miss france
que pour montrer son cul elle peut pas
aussi développer autre chose montrer
autre chose une femme n'est pas belle
que plastic man elle est belle aussi
parce qu'elle dégage est que pour toi le
vin en arrière c'est pas de faire
défiler des firmes et d'un comme les
fruits médias à paris mais justement le
défilé a évolué je veux dire fois aussi
dans le village ou bien moi je vais
faire mentir la monado leur rsa par
coûter une très mauvaise et nation
lorient quelle crème mais je pense que
je dis est mille fois et je alors je
vais écouter une femme deborah elle a le
droit des longs droit d'être intelligent
s'il n'a pas dit quel am a droit sauf
qu'on s'en fout on sent même
chose que ce que j'ai tout fait pour
aller miss france des dernières années
elle avait tout quelque chose de
particulier elle avait une très bonne
élocution elle parlait très bien elles
ont des choses à dire à naples au
créneau
riesch est la priorité c'est le physique
parce que l des filles ont défilé en
maillot de bain en belles robes les
beaux sourires tout le truc qui date des
années mais maintenant les gagnantes
sont souvent loué plus brillants go et
ses plus beaux je t'adore i go go sata
mais n'aurait pas gagné si la lame est
égaux je t'adore mais à force tu vas
sexy bris sa maman parce que c'est
vraiment ici fco je t'adore mais il ya
un moment tu vas me faire croire qu'ils
amec et devant sa télé et bien qu'a
choisi chez pac wamiz miss alsace qui
est hyper bonne escale et tout d'un coup
elle parle et en france qui parle et qui
dit match j'adore les animaux y aura la
guerre [ __ ] change mon coach sait
qu'un livre tu s'exprimer ce qu'il est
mal exprimé qui bavent ceux qui galèrent
à dire son discours elle n'est pas élue
c'est quoi ça yui par lucien viel
coupable non ça serait l'histoire tu
vois une bombe et tout à coup l'un peut
pas bien tu vas te pas pour lui tu
serais mis ça serait mister gay ouais
bon nous prenons les gays à gérer
barbotin oui je suis rêveur boîte de
nuit j'ai vu une bombe ouais je parle
avec il est con comme un manche à balai
je m'en tape guaino ce que je demande à
mes vrais sites le dalloz j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] les gens ne vont pas voter pour
lui d'autant plus qu'il ya un jury et le
jury très exigeant sur sur le discours
est un discours il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît à mélanger
donner la parole je t'adore menace de
donner la parole à un hétéro
hétérosexuelle est le seul non plus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les gens me à
s'écouter tomber dans le panneau de la
communication du comité miss france
quand tu écoutes qui répondant aux
critiques sur le sexisme de la série
ministère a dit non c'est pas une
cérémonie qui ont misé que sur la beauté
ou si on leur pose des questions
culturelles n'acceptera mais
intrinsèquement et sont à pau bêtement
sa concours de beauté mais la ville a du
coup dans son discours désolé aux
familles on vous est catégorique c'est
soit c'est pour le cerveau soit c'est
pour le physique là je trouve qu un
juste milieu qui est doucement bien sûr
aller au lieu de ça elle finalisé jeudi
que des conneries est la priorité on
l'attendait on dit pas qu'elle soit un
code mais qu'elle soit connu ou pas on
s'en va même jusqu'à mais pas aux agents
café puis maintenant et s'il a à g alors
isabelle et ludivine chantre ligne bleue
alors je me tape devant les boeufs ou
trois irlandais voiture est non mais moi
on regarde évidemment que le physique en
revanche il m'est arrivé de caen en
entendant une qui est aimée complètement
nu mm is to ils vont dire bah non là
c'est bien sûr mais là tu prends les
experts le disent mais on se trompe des
débats les enfants à j'adore ça c'est ça
ce sont des visions du la leur
du tout bon débat ce que vous dites
n'importe quoi
c'est pas ça marche en avant sa mort
tout de covile de leur monde et vous
vous êtes quand même
bien on verra bien non on se trompe de
débat j'entends tous vos arguments et je
t'entends hugo évidemment que le
concours a un petit peu évolué
heureusement à l'air demi tout à l'air
de la libération de la parole des femmes
et du fait que voilà les meufs soient
pas des poules de concours heureusement
que ça évolue mais lui te donne pas les
explications le pourquoi du comment miss
france choisit le jury vote tout pas le
mec il dit pour quelles raisons les
téléspectateurs regards et les mecs qui
sont devant leurs élèves dans les écoles
et les fans et leur gamin des véhicules
ludivine et moi je regarde le
tonga mais les rebelles étant déjà un
argument d'internet je n'argumente
rennais tu sais ce que tu disais été
vrai j'aurais pas 99% émission où elle
défile à poil sans parler et une seconde
et demie ou al balawi
[Applaudissements]
canadiens canadiennes
je vais mettre tout le monde à dos mais
en guise de conclusion c'est vrai que
miss univers aux états unis elle doit se
présenter à voir une élocution parfaite
bien sûr effectivement aux états unis
miss univers on a les plus grosses
bombes on est en france
une femme meurt un bel écho fois
effectivement brésilienne japonaises
elles ont besoin de se présenter avec
une bonne élocution est d'une extrême
dans seulement belles qu'on choisit la
beauté l'élocution et au jour
d'aujourd'hui effectivement la miss
france n'est plus haut elle est belle ou
elle adéquate aux ischios ohmydollz
regard son cul ces gens qu est ce qu
elle parle bien l esma cheese maasing on
voit pour elle est bonne dans les deux
sens et on pousse à l'esma donc oui je
dirais 70%
si les locutions et tout ce que tu dis
était si important d'en dessiner mais
rémy cement pourquoi est-ce qu'elle
arriverait tout aussi reçu un oui parce
que aux états unis c'est la loi de la
jeanne
parfaite égérie berbel à la base et
attention il ya des filles qui sont très
belle qui se refont retoucher une rolls
royce a besoin un peu non mais ne donne
un peu d'air attendez je vais vous
arrêter sur ce débat parce que pour moi
c'était c'est tellement faux cul et
après ben non j'ai rien contre ça
pendant un an elles font plein de
festivals plein de soirée elles ont une
écharpe et elle sera cotée de tellier
que j'ai vu faire tu le mets tout dans
l'oreillette tout ce qu'elle doit dire
elle sent que tu es du maire je suis
très contente d'être a besoin de 100 à
120 vivre le rouble chambles chant
acheter un reblochon
voilà tes conneries on en redemande est
belle comme ça une fois invite diane
l'air voit la vie de personnes sur 60
issus la dernière miss traces mathieu ou
arrondie d'amandine petit heymans
boutinot les dernières miss ne sont pas
des débiles alors bien sûr pas les devil
et orateur déjà pas
mal gagné parce qu'elles sont aussi
rangement de sujets please attention
changement de sujet parce que là c'est
beaucoup plus grave
il va mettre fin à sa carrière et c'est
mon idole de qui parle-t-on bon je suis
dit
c'est ma vie
shingai pauvre con je vous sors tout est
effectivement la fille de bruce willis à
propos de son père sam a fait les
manchettes et columbo peter falk avait
annoncé qu'il avait parkinson alzheimer
je m'étais parmi ces gamins et monsieur
qui a 70 ans maintenant un peu plus et
il a dit sa femme a dit aux fans
incroyables du bruce nous la famille
nous voulions vous partagez que notre
bien-aimé bruce a subi quelques
problèmes de santé ces derniers temps
une aphasie lui a récemment été
diagnostiquée ça impacte ses fonctions
cognitives en fonction de cela il ne
pourra plus jamais faire de cinéma en
gros et anna phase il a du mal à parler
à entendre c'est ça mais moi et plus de
mémoire en émoi
[Musique]
voilà c'est c'est surtout
menace aggravée en fait c'est pas
quelque chose qui va s'arranger ni même
ce traité est pire si les seuils de
lutter contre sur des tournages etc ce
sera encore plus compliqué donc il va de
ce fait les frais essai c'est d'ailleurs
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles ces
dernières années il a tourné que dans
des navets c'est parce qu'en fait je
savais qu'il était mal aller en fait il
voulait juste ramasser un maximum
d'argent pour un souvenir bien c'est
plein de choses tristes moi j'avais fait
le dernier plateau de jean pierre
marielle l époque j'étais assistant sur
le logiciel j'ai déjà d'or ce type
cloud mais dans le dock est le sien et
c'était horrible était venu il avait des
petites notes et y lisait et tout ça
c'était d'une dune d'une tristesse sans
nom et pour revenir sur peter falk la
dernière année il était complètement
alzheimer et un jour il est sorti de sa
maison de los angeles et il se promenait
en qu'elles sont nus comme ça et c'est
la police qui l'a ramenée à voilà les
gens qu'on a aimé c'est toujours très
triste mais c'est comme saisir voilà
c'est comme ça on va rire un petit peu
plus oui deborah dit un truc très
important mais non c'est que si le
tournoi de somer
massive d'argent c'est comme n'y a pas
de couverture sociale il faut qu'ils
payent tous les frais d'opération qui va
subir mais votre lycée débat monde
ça va vite ou enfin beau souligner c'est
que d'aucuns y aura pas boudhiste on
pourra les les non mais oui oui oui
voilà dessus il n'est pas la rue ça dois
je suis pas sûr c'était la meilleure la
meilleure intervention deborah je pense
qu'il a touché ce parti mais
extrêmement intelligent ce que j'ai dit
non mais tu es très belle tu pourrais
être nous alors